i'd like to mention i have some rather
upsetting personal news
i'd like to share oh no what's wrong
this time
andy i've again
run out of shows to watch you've run out
of shows to watch
yes this whole quarantine i've been
keeping myself sane
by binging lots and lots of shows and
now i have completely run out
i've literally seen all the stuff
i'm sure i mean there's just no way that
you could have seen all the stuff
i mean i can recommend some more shows
andy i promise you try me
i've watched everything okay um
well you should check out the coming to
america sequel
i watched it the first night it streamed
and uh what about clarice
all caught up you like travel shows and
there's this one about scotland called
men in kilts saw it batwoman bat watched
it
snow piercer saw it bill the chilling
adventures of sabrina the saw
adventures of watched it 90-day fiance
saw it 90-day divorcee
seen it 90-day beyonce saw it doctor who
star nurse where
scene professor howe saw uh how about
horror movies
texas chainsaw massacre texas chain
scene massacre
the haunting of hill house the seeing of
saw house the conjuring the scene
jaws saws okay what about the movie saw
saw yeah
saw have you seen it yeah i saw a saw
that's what i meant when i said saw oh
saw two i saw saw two two did you see
saw three i saw saw three three times
peaky blinders saw it punky brewster saw
it brewster's millions
seen it billions saw it make millions
mix cena mcbillions
mcsod mctrillions nick watsted mick
quadrillions
nathan c nillian ice road truckers scene
ice road cluckers saw
ice road [ __ ] saw nice road suckers
scene to kill a mockingbird saw to catch
a predator
scene two wong fu thanks for everything
julie newmar andy richter saw it conan
o'brien when harry met sally
saw there's something about mary saw
dirty harry met sally and mary at romy
and michelle's high school reunion
scene sleepless in seattle scene hot in
cleveland saw escape from new york seen
mr smith goes to washington
philadelphia seed gangs of new york saw
mr smith escapes the gangs of new york
by becoming a dj for wkrp in cincinnati
c
csi csi
yeah okay i don't think i've seen csi
you've never seen csi i don't think so
well there you go i mean you can binge
on that thing for weeks
great thanks andy well it looks like
your free time just got
less free
maybe i won't watch csi